hey everyone so ant-man and the law
specifically in theaters and it was a
really great movie it had a lot of
action it had a lot of comedy it was
really good if you plan on seeing it
soon you will not be disappointed so
jumping right into it this is a post
credit scene explanation I will be
talking about what happened in the movie
ant-man and the wasp and what happened
post-credit so there will be spoilers
for both the movie and the post credits
scene if you want to just know what the
post credits scene is about and don't
want any spoilers for the movie check
out a video I did that have no spoilers
in the link above and be sure to
subscribe to my channel so you can stay
up to date on everything related to
Avengers 4 so there's a lot of different
aspects to the movie but what it really
comes down to is hope and Hank trying to
get into the quantum realm so they can
get Janet Van Dyne back who is hopes
mother and Hanks wife the end of opening
the quantum realm for a brief period of
time until the machine that they're
using to do it fails in this period of
time Scott Lang receives a message from
hope Van Dyne who is in the quantum
realm the message that Janet put inside
a Scott's head is actually a way to find
her in the quantum realm so this is how
dr. Pym hope and ant-man get back
together and then at the same time you
have one of the villains ghosts who is
trying to steal dr. Hank Pym laboratory
the whole entire movie because she needs
to access the quantum realm as well we
find out that ghost is actually dying
she has a molecular problem with her
cells and she needs the quantum realm in
order to save herself at the end of the
movie dr. Hank Pym goes inside the
quantum realm while ant-man and the
wasps were fighting off ghosts
Hank eventually finds his wife Janet Van
Dyne and they come out of the quantum
room once out of the quantum realm Janet
actually temporarily heals ghosts and
from there it's implied that Janet will
figure out a way to permanently heal
ghosts which leads us into the
post-credits scene the post-credits
scene starts off on a rooftop and it
pans into a picture of dr. Hank Pym and
his wife who is now out of the quantum
realm Janet Van Dyne dr. Hank Pym says I
used to be a respected scientist had my
names on the side of buildings and now
I got this it then turns to Louise's van
which in the back of it has a small
quantum tunnel in it there is then a few
jokes exchanged but then ant-man jumps
out of the front seat and says that it's
ready then hope goes up the ant-man and
she gives him the cylinder looking thing
which she calls a collection unit
basically she says when he opens it
inside of the quantum realm it should
automatically start collecting quantum
healing particles then Janet issues a
warning to Scott telling him to stay out
of the tardigrade fields because they're
cute but they will eat him and then she
mentioned something that is super
important and that is and don't get
sucked into a time vortex we won't be
able to save you more on this in just a
bit ant-man then lines up in front of
the quantum tunnel and then hope starts
a countdown saying okay going subatomic
in five four three two one ant-man then
gets sucked into the quantum realm and
then dr. Hank Pym gets on the radio and
says alright Scott this is a Mic Check
after a few seconds of Scott not
replying everyone kind of starts to get
worried but then eventually he gets on
the radio saying Mic Check one two one
two how's everybody doing in the quantum
realm paint Pinzon says that he reads
him an ant-man opens up the collective
unit and starts to gather the quantum
healing particles after he collects them
all he says okay healing particles
gathered for our new ghost friend so it
is clear that ant-man went inside the
quantum realm to gather these healing
particles so they could permanently find
a solution to fix ghosts molecular cell
problem so ghost is an ally now and then
hope says over the radio great
preparing for re-entry in five four
three and then the microphone cuts out
there's a few seconds of silence and
then ant-man says hello and there's even
more silence and then he says haha
very funny you can see ant-man start to
freak out a little bit as he's just
sitting there floating in the quantum
realm and then he says Hank quit playing
around you told me never to play around
as ant-man starts to freak out even more
continuously yelling guys guys
Janet hope Hank it cuts to the rooftop
in which we see ashes three pile of
ashes where Hank Hope and Janet have
disintegrated from Thanos a snap the
scene ends with ashes surrounding the
microphone in which we hear Scott
yelling guys and
so this is clearly right when Thor had
Stormbreaker in Thanos chest and Thanos
snapped his fingers wiping away half of
the people in the universe from
existence and obviously hope Hank and
Janet were part of those people who got
wiped out
this leaves ant-man stranded inside the
quantum realm so that leaves the
question how is he going to get out
fares kind of a few ways like if Bill
Foster survived the snap maybe he could
find him somehow and get him out of the
quantum realm or if Louise survived the
snap as well and he's on the rooftop
maybe he could somehow figure out how to
work the technology to get him back but
I think were actually told how he's
going to get out in this post-credit
scene where Janet says the time vortex
this makes the most sense because we
have no idea who survived the snap Lois
bill foster ghost they could all be dead
and this ties directly in with the
Avengers for time-travel plot so I think
the answer is that eventually after
waiting for such a long period of time
ant-man is going to find one of those
time vortexes and go through it where
will he end up no idea but Marvel
President Kevin Feige said this movie is
so important and directly links to
Avengers 4 and I think this is the link
so there you have it ant-man and the
Lost post-credit scene breakdown what
did you all think of the movie what did
you all think about the post-credits
scene and how do you think ant-man is
going to get out of the quantum realm
let me know your thoughts in the
comments below if you enjoyed the video
please hit that thumbs up button and
don't forget to subscribe to my channel
so you can stay up to date on Avengers
for all things Marvel DC and superhero
thank you so much for watching woof woof
[Music]
you